oh
i don't care if his head is more
squished i get to see more rupert
friends
it's like that family guy episode when
stewie's head gets pushed in they did
this trailer so good they just showed us
just a bit of the inquisitors the the
lay people of star wars they're like who
the hell are they we have something to
explain just some aurabesh here and
there
a new droid we've never seen before
a only a lightsaber when it's just
spinny spinny spinning oh yeah maybe he
had give me that fan lightsaber
that you just let john williams do all
the heavy lifting here right it's
perfect
so much
what are those birds no one knows it
doesn't looks like more ride but
probably not more eye right
called it so we're right about the
breathing just the breathing mm-hmm
[Music]
yeah it really is they know how they
know their own brand they use those
folks at the house of mouse they just
know how to you know
welcome back to disney channel
i am a lightsaber
you could get hillary duff do it but not
after you did her dirty with that right
hulu series justice for death
justice for death hey now that you have
this parental controls on disney plus
can we get justice for duff back on
disney plus that's right i mean if we
can have daredevil beating the piss out
of wilson fisk yeah surely if we can
have luke cage absolutely clapping
jessica jones i think we can have a few
few scenes of
hillary duff getting clapped by gordo
for crying out loud right
justice for gordon or clapping gordo i
don't know what they do by the way no
shame in their game i hope it's
wonderful
no shame in here
hello welcome back to new rock stars
this obi-wan kenobi trailer proves that
ben kenobi's exile on tatooine was no
desert detox my friends but a
heart-pounding pursuit by inquisitors
and another vicious duel with darth
vader the trailer wisely with old vader
other than the sounds of his breathing
but what other evidence is hidden in
this trailer hinted at vader's presence
just outside the frame what is his
relationship with these inquisitors and
what will be his reaction when he
reunites with
this is wookieleek's our weekly reaction
to the ladies and star wars and i'm here
reacting to the kenobi trailer with
tommy bechtol well we certainly know why
obi-wan aged so much now he was under
constant threat of death and and
destruction so it definitely makes sense
yeah
could we see a moment how like in
revenge of the sith the sith lightning
aged palpatine into the form he was in
the original trilogy are we going to see
a moment where he just gets so scared
his hair turns weird yes there was an
episode of the real ghostbusters where
that happened to ray the cartoon when i
was a child i was very traumatized by
the thought that that could happen so
well we're going to see exactly what
makes kenobi [ __ ] his britches so much
you know this is serious already we're
[ __ ] our britches that's right uh
today's episode we're going to talk
about the shadow who looms so large in
star wars that even trailers that give
us no sighting of him still fall into
that shadow of course darth vader his
coming rematch with kenobi his
relationship with the inquisitors and
the way he's gonna leave the series so
pissed off that he's gonna go extra hard
on those rebel soldiers in rogue one oh
my god he's going expert vote yes
giving them just enough hope to to think
that door is going to budge open but no
no no no no
no no no my friends
not today
not today our merch partners at epic
hero shop just re-released a bunch of
cool star wars themed merch including
the exclusive shirts they made from
mandalorian season two in the book of
boba fett can always count on those epic
hero nuts for finding a way to make a
dollar off of whatever the greatest
latest trailer will be
it's a super limited run so you're going
to want to grab one of these or replace
your old mando shirt that you've worn so
much it looks like it was washed in a
sarlacc pit wait is this for me
no this is for me look at this oh wow i
am eric wasser it's dustin away like the
cora mata
the lucasfilm logo i love it dustin away
into the sands of tatooine i love it
right it looks so like i don't have time
to watch it
yeah you're too busy fighting crime at
night after you do breakdown videos it's
like
unbirthing myself out of a sarlacc right
that's just the asset of the song
eating away your armor it's hey the
shirt's just doing an impression of this
part of my chin with the gray patch
that's now coming out oh i got it too
are you going to say one of my favorite
memes that came out of the kenobi
trailer was the one where
he is looking through the binoculars and
it's
boba fett covered in the dust on the
speeder bike just kind of smiling
my favorite is when it's obi-wan looking
out and through the lens of binoculars
it's just paddington
paddington always paddington wins every
meme uh we love you patty paddington if
you're a fan call in we'd love to hear
from you yes justice for padding justice
clap paddington's cheeks
i am in a hotel at universal studios
right now shouting clap paddington's
cheeks through the thin walls i'm sure
oh man that teenager who is too much of
an [ __ ] on the drive down he says
fine you're going to spend first day in
the hotel and you just had to hear
everything
[Music]
anyway well this is supposed to be our
merch plug so head on over to epic hero
shop.com and get get a shirt yes get a
shirt well tommy yes
that's a big question heading out of
this kenobi trailer eric i'm gonna throw
in a good old-fashioned what the fat
what the [ __ ] does the new kenobi
trailer tell us about darth vader in
this series nothing and everything
uh really this trailer focuses largely
on our friends the inquisitors it's a
group of jedi hunters who can seem a bit
overwhelming if you haven't seen rebels
or played fallen order read those 2015
darth vader comics you should for all
three of those especially those comments
yes those comics are incredible yes eric
thank you for sharing a few of those
comics with me recently i do not regret
reading them at all it is uh it's just
as emotional to find out the secrets
that we already know seeing them on a
comic book page makes it all the more
fun and rich so i i can't remember you
really just
second by second what's running through
vader's mind you know uh it's it's
now the identity of each inquisitor i'm
going to say might be
might be less important than who the
group is as a whole because honestly up
until this point at least
eventually
most of these inquisitors either get
killed off by the jedi they're pursuing
or vader will execute them for being
weak um but really the grant the grand
inquisitor has been the most interesting
he was present for ahsoka's false
persecution during the clone wars and
then of course we met the second sister
trilogy super fun to follow in the game
fallen order but if you're new to all
this just don't get caught up on the
numerical designations fifth brother
seventh sister eighth brother really
they were just numbered this way to
suggest that there are a lot of them and
they are in a certain hierarchy it's
kind of like that high school prank
where you paint numbers on chickens and
release them in the halls but you skip
number 12 so the teachers keep looking
for that 12th chicken that doesn't exist
what high school did you go to
one in the south we got more chickens we
know it's doing number 12 must have been
eaten by a gator or a jaguar jaguars
man my chicken would take your jaguar
any day of the week especially since
mine's a ghost ghost chicken that ghost
chicken's in the boy's locker room i
know it i've seen it i've seen that
ghost chicken he's still there ghost
chicken how's my dreams coming to cbs i
want to marry that ghost chicken
as long as that goes chicken don't say
gay here in florida that's right that
goes trick it's fine by my boat you can
say i'm going to marry and spend the
rest of my life with a chicken but if
you say gay in florida you turn to stone
swear to god it doesn't say that
anywhere in that bill it's just heavily
implied because that's the whole reason
we're introducing this bill as a
solution to a problem that doesn't exist
welcome to florida you don't pay income
taxes but if you live a certain way that
we don't agree with we're going to make
you want to kill yourself guess what
it's also illegal to put a saddle on a
unicorn now we passed that law as well
you can't put a saddle on a unicorn and
you're not allowed to ride the loch ness
monster like falcore both illegal in
florida now
keep testing me i will ban all mythical
creatures there's walls in that hotel at
universal studios you know they have a
squad on the other side of that wall
who's just like listening are you saying
they've got inquisitor
so you teaching a second grader oh my
god what gay is i swear to god a minion
with a blowtorch is going to come in and
smoke me the desantis saints are coming
for you my friend
the desantis
um anyway we're going to meet a new
inquisitor on this series riva she's
designated as the third sister but we
have no idea what her fate will be after
the series because she doesn't show up
anywhere else but that doesn't mean she
dies she could just be on some other
mission she could have a change of heart
we'll find out but the important thing
to focus on is the inquisitor's
relationship with darth vader their
fortress is on the ocean moon of ner
which is a secret location that they
moved to in order to be closer to
vader's castle of mustafar visually
their fortress their ships even their
furniture evokes vader's castle design
he was one who trained them to hunt jedi
they worship him they also fear him but
also vader gives him a kind of buffer
protection from the emperor because the
emperor is not crazy about the
inquisitor's existence he doesn't want
other force wielders to be out and about
so that puts a lot of pressure on the
grand inquisitor and on vader and for
the inquisitors to deliver to finish the
job of order 66 to produce results so
when we see the inquisitors on this
series they're going to be our gateway
to vader in this story in the shots of
the fortress inquisitorius we see a
lambda class shuttle on that landing pad
and inside there's a throne that looks
like vader's thrown almost like a family
having to permanently keep empty papa's
lazy boy that's his seat don't sit there
in case he ever comes back from getting
those cigarettes the dealers are gonna
be on any minute he's coming back he's
gonna watch him i know he's coming back
papa is it you no it's just a truck that
looks like his
anyway so um yeah that's he's gonna have
a connection with him we're just gonna
see like it's kind of creepy when we see
a villain and the people who now follow
in the villa instead like vader was
always seemed kind of like the rogue old
timer in the company who's choking
people during meetings no he's got a
whole squad of people who have like
built themselves in there in his image
so uh it's gonna be fascinating to see
what hap it's like in righteous
gemstones where uh we see the youngest
son kelvin yeah he's got
the buff guys the muscle man follow him
get your muscle boys out of here
yeah that's kind of what we're looking
at here yes so i think what's going to
happen is riva and the other inquisitors
are chasing down a force sensitive
fugitive to tatooine and while there
they sense obi-wan's presence maybe not
knowing it's obi-wan but some other jedi
is nearby also probably sensing luke's
presence so obi-wan to protect luke has
to lure them off world of this planet of
daiyu but now he's exposed and obi-wan
is going to alert his presence to vader
leading to their rematch now a question
we should ask here
will vader at this point learn about
luke or leia the answer is no there is
an amazing moment in the 2015 darth
vader comics which are considered canon
by the way depicting the moment that
vader learns about luke and this is
right after the battle of yavin vader
asks boba fett about the rebel pilot who
blew up the death star
and boba fett says he only learned the
name skywalker and in that moment vader
connects the dots he remembers padme
dying and realizing she died in
childbirth uh
he says i have a son he remembers it
his fist clinches in the glass on the
bridge of his star destroyer crack and
he he swears that luke will be his all
of it will be his so that's the moment
he learns and there's no freaking way
this show is going to erase that moment
that's a really incredible such a really
nice uh
really nice plate for him to betray the
emperor or for him to turn against her
what a dick
first moment what a poor move i made him
think everybody was just dead yeah yeah
you killed her no
it can't be i felt her presence yes so
i think
really what that tells us is throughout
their battle in the series obi-wan is
going to preserve that secret the secret
of luke and leia and the secret of how
padme really died and from that we can
conclude that the conflict between these
two is not going to be over padme as
much as it will be rooted in their own
friendship between the two of them which
brings up the fact that we're probably
going to see some flashbacks to the
clone wars i spot in the trailer the two
escape pods right that tells that
happened during uh order
right after order 66 um during the
epilogue of uh revenge of the sith so
we're going to go back to those moments
and show how all those events really
unfolded
so
that's the that's the connection that's
the relationship they're gonna have the
the moment of uh you and my brother
anakin i loved you
uh it's gonna be a bitter brother's feud
uh between the characters as we knew him
in the latter seasons of the animated
clone wars as opposed to the lover's
quarrel a sort of love triangle as
anakin kind of concocted it and yeah
that we saw in revenge of the sith well
one is reality such a smarter way to do
it yeah well one is the reality and one
is the emotional
uh manipulation of the emperor coming to
full manifestation right like the
emperor has clouded anakin's mind so
much at that point that the logical
conclusions that he's jumping to are all
the people that love and care about him
have turned on him and just this one
random guy is the only guy he can trust
which i've been there everybody knows
i've been groomed by a cult leader
before uh down close
but uh and then another one currently i
assume new rockstars is turning into a
call yes we all praise john costa praise
him
praise god
all hell justice for costume justin clap
cost his cheeks uh
we got to put a youtube warning label on
this one they're gonna be like i don't
like the
i don't like the the the turn
rock stars by the by the hillary duff
that's true
we're trending by the way uh yeah we
will be covering how i met your father
on new rockstar starting next week with
my weekly father figure breakdowns
um yeah uh so i i think it's a much
smarter way to do this because it makes
it personal yeah absolutely that that
was a crazy moment i thought and look i
don't want to sound like i'm criticizing
revenge of the sith because i think by
far it's it's definitely in the top half
of star wars movies for me the more i
rewatch it the more i love it um but
that was a weird moment where it just
seems like anakin just goes a little
crazy when padme comes back and meets
someone moves too far it just seems a
little rushed the fact that he forced
chokes or just by looking at obi-wan
yeah they were on the same ship
yeah
the two of you like the fact that he
would jump to that conclusion it's just
how far gone must you be it seems a
little out of character for him to jump
to that i agree and i even think in the
credit to even though uh hayden
christensen has been maligned on how he
portrayed anakin in some ways and has
kind of gotten a little more of his due
as as uh
as it's as the years have passed i think
his his his his realization in the line
if you're not with me then you're my
enemy it's kind of him being like well
maybe i am wrong about all this but it's
too far now and and what is clear to me
is that we're not on the same page and
we are no longer fighting for the same
cause so now i have no choice but to try
and kill you which is the actions of a
crazy person who is maybe seeing just
slightly clearly for the first time like
you know like all right
maybe i have been maybe i have gone
really far down this path but
i still don't trust you and i still you
know and whatever i'm still i've still
been turned completely against you so
well yeah and i i never think this is
the fault of hayden christensen or
really any of the actors i think hayden
christensen is a much more talented
actor that he's been given credit for i
just think he has been um you know
he's been
linked so clearly with this character in
this huge trilogy in the early 2000s i
think he um uh it's really the writing
of the scene yeah and uh that's often
what people say is george lucas's
writing i don't want to fault george
lucas too much either because really he
just tried to frame it as you know only
a sith deals in absolutes and it's just
the the orthodoxy of the sith but it
makes the orthodoxy of the sith too
stupid yeah i think in that moment that
like if you're not with me you're my
enemy i wouldn't even say like justice
for the sith orthodoxy right like they
actually uh the whole point of revenge
of the sith is supposed to show how the
sith made some pretty good points right
and are equally flawed as the jedi right
but i didn't really get that but
honestly i think that's often my problem
with these movies that turn people
against each other i felt this way in uh
captain america's civil war it's just so
hard to make that earned for people who
fought for so many years on the same
side would want to kill each other yeah
to get to reach that level of like we're
massacring
each other and younglings like it's like
yeah it's it was never going to be an
easy task to ticket yes
not to say that never happens in the
real world obviously friends turn on
each other all the time but it's always
such a messy annoying thing that it's
like hard to make a good story out of
that even though yes
shakespeare ancient greek myth there's
plenty of examples of friends turned foe
i get that sure it's just like in modern
pop culture it's hard to show that in a
plausible way if they started as truly
wholesome
loving friends it'd be one thing if they
started as like business rivals right or
something like that or people who were
brought together by circumstance as
opposed to people who had a genuine
affection for each other right brothers
um yeah so anyway i
you might disagree with some of this
analysis i understand but i think really
what george lucas was writing that
moment if you're not wiki or my enemy i
think there was a veiled critique of the
the bush administration war on terror
right like the the bush doctrine was if
you're not on our side one of our
enemies that's right what a what a crazy
kind of logic to get food there's only
that one
shame on you
twice
shame booming i ain't gonna get fooled
again
again
um mission accomplished
and i think that's kind of an issue that
you see in a lot of movies from that era
from 2005 definitely in christopher
nolan's dark knight movies uh batman
begins in the dark knight there's all
this like war on terror
because it was so it was everywhere it
was in everything definitely in uh uh uh
the first iron man oh yeah it's not a
weird like uh
yeah absolutely so it's just kind of
everywhere so it might not uh feel the
same to us now um but i love what
they're doing now i think they are uh
they've learned their lessons from what
fans loved about the clone wars series
where we just saw this this true
affection for each other and i think it
can in a good way recontextualize what
we saw in revenge of the sith as there
was a deeper betrayal that maybe the
writing didn't touch on in that moment
uh between these two characters uh a
student who always felt second guessed
by his master uh denied uh
what are just natural natural instincts
uh by a cruel dogma of
you know
isolation and meditation and uh denying
one's uh uh he didn't stick earthly
pleasures of just love yeah just being
attracted to someone and the desire to
have companionship uh which is just a
no-go you gotta delete all the apps when
you join the jedi you got to get off
bumble you got to get off
saber you got to get off all of them all
of it
all of it um well i can't wait to see
this rematch uh go down and see what it
looks like when these two talk to each
other once more uh and just to see you
know as opposed to oh whereas once i was
a student now i am the master
someone who maybe doesn't have that
confidence yet
but still all the rage in the world yes
still very angry right
still very angry well uh we have a
couple more questions that i haven't had
a chance to talk to anyone about since
this trailer came out uh the questions
of uh the fallen order calcus
why they might have redesigned uh the
look of the grand inquisitor uh and uh
uh revisiting some of the predictions we
made for this trailer on last week's
episode but first we want to thank our
friends at babel for helping us make
this episode sponsoring us for most of
us learning a second language in high
school or college wasn't exactly a high
point in our academic careers i've only
retained how to say where is the library
in spanish and that has come in handy in
approximately zero times because i don't
go to libraries
i fear them they're coarse and
irritating but now thanks to babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just having some free time
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world living in california you
don't even need to travel to put
language skills to work whether i'm
learning spanish or french italian babel
has 14 languages that they offer
and i know there are native speakers not
far from me here where i live that i can
now connect with thanks to babel plus
babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent they have podcasts games tools
stories even live classes plus it comes
in a 20-day money-back guarantee so
start your language learning journey
today with babble and right now when you
purchase a three month babble
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use the promo code wookie
that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code wookie w-o-o-k-i-e-e
that's battle language for life we also
want to thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode we're pretty confident in
our theories here on wikileaks and
confidence can take you pretty far in
life and in the bedroom that's where
blue chew comes in bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in shipable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can plan ahead
or be ready for whenever an opportunity
arises the process is simple you sign up
at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you will receive
your prescription within days it's all
done online no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting in line with pharmacy bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discreet package so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform bluetooth can help and
we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code new rockstars at checkout
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code new
rockstars to receive your first month
free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
show and we want to thank coinbase for
sponsoring this episode are you starting
to feel a little crypto curious maybe
you saw a super bowl commercial or your
smart friend keeps talking about it and
you're starting to feel like you're the
last one to the party well if you're
ready to dip your toes in the warm
waters of crypto our friends at coinbase
are here to help coinbase offers a
trusted and easy to use platform to buy
sell and spend cryptocurrency they
support the most popular digital
currencies on the market and they make
them accessible to everyone they offer
portfolio management protection learning
resources and a mobile app so you can
trade securely and monitor your crypto
all in one place millions of people in
over 100 countries trust coinbase with
their digital assets whether you're
looking to diversify just getting
started or searching for a better way to
access crypto markets start today with
coinbase for a limited time new users
can get ten dollars in free bitcoin when
you sign up today at coinbase.com
wookie sign up at coinbase.com wookie
for ten dollars in free bitcoin this
offer is for a limited time only so be
sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com
wookie all right uh tommy in this kenobi
trailer we revisit the fortress
inquisitorius a location that we visit
in the game jedi fallen order
when we were playing this calcus one of
the jedi who escaped order 66 certainly
a target of the inquisitors so do you
think calcestus could show up in this
show make a cameo eric not only do i
think he can i
i'm owed this justice for tommy
cal class this clap tommy's cheeks
because i
spent so much time solving the stupid
puzzles in that game which i enjoyed
very much and i'm just calling them
stupid because they were smarter than me
i
love calcus i like the actor that voiced
him and i assumed in some of the motion
captioning cameron monaghan i
yeah they voiced the look of cameron um
of course it's on camera again he'd be
the perfect actor i think there's no
need to cast i think just get him
i think it is a great way to blend the
lore of video games into the live-action
shows it's a home run to me i think like
even even if it's just a cameo even if
he just helps kenobi
in one episode i i i need this to happen
to make to have made playing fallen
order all worth it although it was
awesome to yeah actually it's worth it
for other reasons yeah i mean you get to
throw a lightsaber at
a stormtrooper it's worth it for many
many reasons but i just
i spent so many hours of my life on it i
just need more calculus to to make it
all seem worthwhile i'm um the fact that
in boba fett we saw a bd droid yeah i
know yeah
that was a little indicator from
lucasfilm that they're like we're gonna
be bringing stuff from that game into
live action and i've always wondered
there was that cool moment in uh in fall
and order where people are talking about
the fate of yattle
are you talking about master seattle and
they're like no i wasn't talking about
we're not really sure what happened to
master seattle i i would just think that
would be fascinating to see yaddles at
some point show up yeah
i i i i should be clear i loved that
game but like all video games i'm not
good at it so i it could be i spent 9
000 hours playing it but in the end when
i beat it i did shed a single tear for
calcus and his uh survival so uh come on
back cal water's warm water's warm dip
your toe in all right tommy let's talk
about the grand inquisitor redesign
now the grand inquisitor is played by
rupert friend in the show he's really
just kind of wearing face paint he's got
the the markings on his face but the
grand inquisitor is supposed to be the
puan race a pow on race i'm sorry if i'm
mispronouncing that um and star wars has
already shown us one of these in live
action remember there was that moment
when obi-wan went to utah in revenge of
the sith and we saw one of them he's
like they're already yeah they have
these spiky teeth they're really
elongated heads they look awesome yeah i
gotta say that was one of my favorite
character designs they were basically
sid so uh that was who
the grand inquisitor is supposed to be
um voiced by jason isaacs and star wars
rebels
why didn't they do this for rupert
friend i
it could be as simple as the prosthetics
were too difficult to work in and
they're just like you know what retcon
it and just have him have the face
markings that are similar and familiar
because i don't understand because they
looked amazing like you said in revenge
of the sith like that looked really
really cool i don't understand why they
would do that other than maybe they want
it to look more like rupert friend you
know like they want to like yeah i think
that's my thinking maybe rupert friend
in his audition just was doing some
crazy
stuff with his face and facial
expressions and when they tried out the
prosthetics prosthetics can be great but
they can also be really limiting to the
actor they it forces them to do a lot
more with their eyes and with their
voice and maybe just like the
the intensity of his performance wasn't
coming through the prosthetics yeah i
don't really know could be um could be a
thing where yeah that maybe they did for
all we know we're gonna get some like
you know bonus footage of of him doing
screen tests in that elongated head and
then an explanation from john favreau
that makes us all go
yeah
i'm willing to give it a chance look i
mean yeah i'm not gonna be too
protective about it if rupert friend
wins me over with his acting i'm that's
good enough for me yes yes all right
let's uh revisit last week's episode we
made uh some predictions for what would
be in this trailer and i just think it'd
be fun to go back and look at what we
predicted and see how accurate we were
uh the first thing we asked would we see
hayden christensen's scarred face in
this trailer we both said no
just and tommy you said we'd hear the
sounds of vader breathing which you're
right ding ding ding ding ding got that
correct yeah um which is great we don't
we don't want to see hayden's scarred
face here that should be a big reveal on
the show i think don't show us that
yeah we don't need that yet now we asked
about the force ghost of qui-gon uh
tommy you said we might hear liam
neeson's voice i suggested that if we
see it at all it would just be maybe the
blue glow
of that uh both of us were incorrect i
think the closest we got was uh you and
mcgregor's voice is a bit echoey yes yes
but uh other than that yeah
that's okay that's okay they're not you
know what
it was just we were just thinking about
it we're just tossing out some fun you
know uh tommy i believe at one point you
said we would see benny safety playing a
cooked out max reboot how disappointed
were you when that didn't happen uh not
yet you know what i'm gonna watch all
the episodes and it has to not happen
for me to be disappointed otherwise i'm
gonna keep holding on for that to happen
uh you know my boy max
he's got to get some more screen time
he's he's he's he's the he's the most
consistent member of that franchise does
the same thing every time so come on
kill
[Laughter]
just sitting on the bathroom floor
crying
left me again
nothing i have nothing
maybe someone let me always die
[Laughter]
but his feet are so weird doesn't he
play the piano with his feet didn't we
get that drawing from not anymore no no
you know
actually i gotta make a prediction i
think benny saffy is playing that
runaway or sensitive fugitive that they
execute i think that's gonna be a short
role for him hey that's a prediction
just prediction uh i want to get one
last look at you
we uh predicted uh we asked would we see
obi-wan's lightsaber igniting in this
trailer uh we didn't until the very end
we saw a blue lightsaber make the disney
plus logo yeah
right in a way
yes we got there we asked would we see
alderaan in this trailer we said maybe
and if so that would be indication that
leo would for sure show up no sighting
of older not yet no and maybe not ever
maybe not fc i'll say this i don't need
it i don't need it in the show i don't
either leia doesn't show up that's
totally okay because that's where you
get a season two that's right
to kenobi too furious let's do it
justice for han
and then we asked would we see camille
non-gianni in this trailer we said yes
but we didn't see him unless he's
playing that droid ned right we won't
know until we hear his voice we did get
i mean after matthew berry voiced that
droid in ob in uh boba fett i'm the
sky's the limit for for voice act for
for stars voicing droids now it's just
nothing could please me more um and
lastly we asked would we see lightsabers
clashing between obi-wan and vader uh no
no side innovator obviously we saw the
spinning lightsabers of the inquisitors
we saw obi-wan's lightsaber igniting at
the end but right now it seems like
obi-wan's trying to avoid outing himself
as a jedi so he doesn't want to use a
lightsaber fighting them yet yeah so uh
exciting to watch this with you tommy
absolutely exciting to have this in our
lives we want you guys every week tweet
at us at new rockstars your biggest star
wars questions because that's what we're
going to be talking about between now
and may 25th uh until we get another
trailer until we get more news about the
star wars every week every monday tommy
and i are gonna be talking about the
latest and greatest in star wars we're
so glad we get to do this with you yes
um
but we'll leave it there for this
episode of wookie leaks don't forget to
check out our many great merch options
over newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at
ea boss follow tommy and tommy back to
the following rockstars subscribe to
wikileaks wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching and uh goodbye
that
and tommy just try to
lay low layla's slow there in florida
because it's the dangerous world so good
i don't think that everything's trying
to kill you i don't think anyone can get
me as long as i don't say
you